there's another new late-night talk show  it's on cable yet another one take a  look it's time for talk show hosted by a  golden retriever this week scooters got  after Reid harvest every two to three  minutes  and scooter show some love to director  Doug can you help me out please  musical guest Rachel originally this  week scooters got would you pee on it  plus getaway mailman and wall of smells  then scooter cooks with celebrity chef  Marcia Pat has we need that for the beet  soup plus a touching tribute to the  comedian that gave scooter his stunt  Barney Lagrange all new scooter tonight  on what network MSNBC MSNBC  [Applause]  [Music]